when someone mentions Cuba what do you
think about classic classic cars
perhaps good cigars maybe think of a
famous baseball player what about when
somebody mentions North Korea do you
think about those missile tests maybe
they're notorious leader or his good
friend Dennis Rodman one thing that
likely doesn't come to mind
he's a vision of a country an open
economy whose citizens have access to a
wide range of affordable consumer
products I'm not here to argue how these
countries got to where they are today I
simply want to use them as an example of
countries and citizens who have been
affected negatively affected by a trade
policy that restricts imports and
protects local industries recently we've
heard a number of countries talk about
restricting imports and protecting their
local domestic industries now this may
sound fine in a soundbite but what it
really is is protectionism we heard a
lot about this during the 2016
presidential election we heard about it
during the brexit debates and most
recently during the French elections in
fact it's been a really important topic
being talked about around the world and
many aspiring political leaders are
running on platforms positioning
protectionism as a good thing now I
could see why they think protectionism
is good because sometimes it seems like
trade is unfair some have blamed trade
for some of the problems we've been
having here at home in the US for years
we've been hearing about the loss of
high-paying US manufacturing jobs many
think that manufacturing is declining in
the US because companies are moving
their operations offshore to markets
with lower cost labor like China Mexico
and Vietnam
they also think trade agreements
sometimes are unfair like NAFTA and the
trans-pacific partnership because cheese
trade agreements allow companies to
reimpose cheaply produced goods back
into the u.s. in other countries from
where the jobs were taken so it kind of
feels like the exporters win and the
importers lose now the reality is output
in the manufacturing sector in the US is
actually growing but we are losing jobs
we're losing lots of them in fact from
2000 to 2010 5.7 million manufacturing
jobs were lost but they're not being
lost for the reasons you might think
Mike Johnson in Toledo Ohio didn't lose
his job at the factory to me again
sánchez and one third a mythical know
Mike lost his job to a machine
eighty-seven percent of lost
manufacturing jobs have been eliminated
because we've made improvements in her
own productivity through automation so
that means that one out of ten lost
manufacturing jobs was due to offshoring
now this is not just a u.s. phenomenon
no in fact automation is spreading to
every production line in every country
around the world but look I get it if
you just lost your job and then you read
in the newspaper that your old company
just struck up a deal with China it's
easy to think you were just replaced in
a one-for-one deal when I hear stories
like this I think that what people
picture is that trade happens between
only two countries manufacturers in one
country produce products and they export
them to consumers in other countries and
it feels like the manufacturing
countries win and the importing
countries lose well reality's a little
bit different I'm a supply chain
professional and I live and work in
Mexico
and I work in the middle of a highly
connected network of manufacturers all
collaborating from around the world to
produce many of the products we use
today what I see from my front row seat
in Mexico City actually looks more like
this and this is a more accurate
depiction of what trade really looks
like I've had the pleasure of being able
to see how many different products are
manufactured from golf clubs to laptop
computers to Internet servers
automobiles and even airplanes believe
me none of it happens in a straight line
let me give you an example a few months
ago I was touring the manufacturing
plant of a multinational aerospace
company in Canada Mexico and the BP
logistics points out a completed tail
assembly it turns out the tail
assemblies are assembled from panels
that are manufactured in France and
they're assembled in Mexico using
components imported from the US when
those tail assemblies are done they're
exported via truck to Canada to their
primary assembly plant where they come
together with thousands of other parts
like the wings and the seats and the
little shades over the little windows
all coming in to become a part of a new
airplane think about it these new
airplanes before they even take their
first flight they have more stamps in
their passport than Angelina Jolie now
this approach to processing goes on all
around the world to manufacture many of
the products we use every day from skin
cream to airplanes when you go home
tonight take a look in your house you
might be surprised to find a label that
looks like this one manufactured in the
USA from u.s. and foreign parts
economist Michael Porter described
what's going on here best many decades
ago he said that it's most beneficial
for a country to focus on producing
the products it can produce most
efficiently and trading for the rest so
what he's talking about here is shared
production an efficiency is the name of
the game you've probably seen an example
of this at home or at work let's take a
look at an example think about how your
house was built or your kitchen
renovated typically there's a general
contractor who is responsible for
coordinating the efforts of all the
different contractors an architect to
draw the plans a earthmoving company to
dig the foundation a plumber a carpenter
and so on so why doesn't the general
contractor pick just one company to do
all the work like say the architect
because this is silly the general
contractor selects experts because it
takes years to learn and master how to
do each of the tasks it takes to build a
house or renovate a kitchen
some of them requiring special training
think about it would you want your
architect to install your toilet of
course not so let's apply this process
to the corporate world companies today
focus on manufacturing what they produce
best and most efficiently and they trade
for everything else so this means they
rely on a global interconnected
interdependent network of manufacturers
to produce these products in fact that
network is so interconnected it's almost
impossible to dismantle and produce
products in just one country let's take
a look at the interconnected web we saw
a few moments ago and let's focus on
just one strand between the US and
Mexico the Wilson Institute says that
share production represents 40% of the
half a trillion dollars in trade between
the u.s. and Mexico that's about 200
billion dollars or the same as the GDP
for Portugal so let's just imagine that
the u.s. decides to impose a 20% border
tax on all imports from Mexico
okay fine but do you think Mexico is
just gonna stand by and let that happen
no no way so retaliation they impose
similar tax on all goods being imported
from the US and a little game of
tit-for-tat ensues and 20% just imagine
that 20% duties are added to every good
product product component crossing back
and forth across the border and you
could be looking at more than a 40
percent increase in duties or eighty
billion dollars don't kid yourself these
costs are going to be passed along to
you and to me now let's think about what
that impact might have on some of the
products or the prices of the products
that we buy every day so if the 30%
increase in duties were actually passed
along we would be looking at some pretty
important increases in prices a Lincoln
MKZ would go from $37,000 to 48,000 and
the price of a sharp 60 inch HDTV would
go from eight hundred ninety eight
dollars to one thousand one hundred and
sixty-seven dollars and the price of a
16-ounce jar of CBS skin moisturizer
would go from thirteen dollars to
seventeen dollars now remember this is
only looking at one strand of the
production chain between US and Mexico
so multiply this out across all of the
strands the impact could be considerable
now just think about this even if we
were able to dismantle this network and
produce products in just one country
which by the way is easier said than
done
we would still only be saving or
protecting one out of ten lost
manufacturing jobs that's right because
remember most of those jobs 87 percent
were lost due to improvements in our own
productivity and unfortunately those
jobs they're gone for good so the real
question is does it make sense for us to
drive up prices
to the point where many of us can't
afford the basic goods we use every day
for the purpose of saving a job that
might be eliminated in a couple of years
anyway the reality is that sure
production allows us to manufacture
higher quality products at lower costs
it's that simple it allows us to get
more added limited resources and
expertise we have and at the same time
benefit from lower prices it's really
important to remember that for shared
production to be effective it relies on
efficient cross-border movement of raw
materials components and finished
products so remember this the next time
you're hearing somebody try to sell you
on the idea that protectionism is a good
deal it's just not thank you
[Applause]